週刊金融日記
2026年9月15日 第七百四十八号
エーアイにより我々の知的生産性は爆上げしてめちゃくちゃ多忙になり暮らしに余裕もなく
なりましたが収入も増えません
トランプ大統領が選挙で共和党勝利なら5000ドル給付
品川駅周辺のラーメンの話
小型原発銘柄の将来性について
他
web版
こんにちは。
ふじさわかずきです。
週末は、広州の方に、またスノボをしに行ってきました。
香港の近くのスキー場は、深
センが新しくて規模も大きくて良いという話なんですが、こっちは混んでて、古い広州の
方が良いという話なんですよね。
しんせんの方はまだ行ったことないんですが。
南国で夏にスノボするのもいいですね。
前回も気になったんですが、日本って、ちゃんとレギュラースタンス（左足が前）かグ
ーフィー（右足が前）かでレンタルするじゃないですか。
しかし、前回も、僕はレギュラ
ーだ！
と何度言っても、うちは同じボードしかないと言われて、なんか戸惑って、どうや
って滑っていいか分からんかったんですが（すぐ慣れましたが……）、今回、ようやく
謎が解けました。
効率化を優先するために、ほぼ左右対称なダックスタンスというので、中国のチケット
に含まれている無料レンタルはやってるらしいのです。
これだと右も左もありませんから
ね。
さらに、調べると、僕たちおっさんがスノボやり始めた20年ぐらい前というのは、ス
ノボが新しく、スキーからの転向が多いんで、前振りと言って、進行方向につま先が向
くようにアングルがついてて（僕はこれで練習してたんですが）、その後、いろいろなス
ノボならではのトリックが流行って、どっち向きでも滑れて、グルっと回ったりがやりや
すいダックスタンス（アヒルの足が外側に向いているやつ）が主流になったようなんです
わ。
それで、ダックスタンスだと、本来はちょっとアングル付けたりするんですが、左右
対称でも問題ないんで、効率化するために、右も左もないやつが中国では無料レンタルに
なっている、と。
それで自前のボードでも買おうと思ったんですが、中国の高速鉄道は、荷物の大きさ的
にボードはダメらしくて、どうしたもんかな、と思っているところですね。
広州はスキー場みたいな観光地でも、物価がしんせんより一段と安くていいですね。
こん
だけ新鮮なビーフの火鍋をたらふく食べて、１人3000円とかですからね。
週末にエーアイかいはつを減速させようみたいな話が出てきて、ちょっと株は売られていますね。
まあ、単なるたわごとなんですけどね。
エーアイ開発「減速」は可能なのか？
激しい競争と「中国リスク」が壁に
ダリオさんとか、エーアイ作るのはすごいけど、こういう政治の話とかはダメなんで、そうい
うのは自分で考えずに、Fableに丸投げして、Fableの言うとおりに動いてほしいです
Xサブスク（月３USD）は、アップルやグーグルにピンハネされるスマホのXアプリか
らではなく、宇宙かいはつを応援するためにも、天才イーロン・マスクさんのXのWebをブラ
ウザで開いていただいて、そこから直接ポチっていただけると助かります。
品川駅周辺の美味しいレストランをとうとうまとめました！
（Xサブスク）
こんしゅうも読者から興味深い投稿がいくつもあります。
見どころは以下のとおりです。
-日本の長期金利４％時代に海外駐在家庭はどう生活防衛すべきでしょうか
-しんせんへの直行便と買い物旅行について
-ブセナテラス以外の沖縄のおすすめホテルをご教示ください
-小型原発銘柄に将来性はありますか
それではこんしゅうもよろしくお願いします。
１．エーアイにより我々の知的生産性は爆上げしてめちゃくちゃ多忙になり暮らしに余裕もなく
なりましたが収入も増えません
オープンエーアイの公開されているジーピーティー-6よりはるかに強力な内部のエーアイが数学の未解決問題を解
いたり、Fableも5.1になったりと、最近、エーアイの性能が上がって、僕はめちゃくちゃ嬉しい
です。
いや、メモリ半導体のメーカーに投資していて持ってる株で儲かるとか、そういう
小ざかしい話じゃなくて、なんというか、めちゃくちゃ有能な部下が100人できた、みた
いな感じですね。
しかも、この部下たちは、給料を要求しない（それぞれ月200USDぐら
いはかかりますが……）、寝ない、どんな要求にも文句を言わない、飲み会とかもない、
何してもパワハラで訴えてこない、と夢のような職場になりました。
問題は、彼らが決して家に帰らないので、それで、マネジャーである僕も帰れないこと
です。
この話をこんしゅうはしようと思います。
[EN]●On the Navier?Stokes Millennium Prize Problem[/EN]
[EN]●Introducing Claude Fable 5.1 and Claude Mythos 5.1[/EN]
こうして、僕の知的生産性は爆上がりしてるわけですが、どう上がっているのかはさま
ざまな分野で多岐にわたるので、おいおいメルマガに書いていきますが、分かりやすいの
は、このメルマガそのものでしょう。
まだエーアイがおバカさんだったほんの２年前、2024年６月のメルマガを読んでみましょう。
世界の自動車産業の概要を解説した号です。
『週刊金融日記 第六百三十一号 読めば５分で分かる世界の自動車産業 - なぜ欧州の対中国EV関税
でドイツが困るのか？
』
僕はググって出てきた記事や統計データを読みながら、Excelとかも使って、ひーこ
ら、メーカー別の自動車販売台数（2023年）と国別の自動車生産台数（2023年）のランキ
ング表を作りました。
いまや中国が年間3000万台も自動車を生産していて、メーカー別で
もBYDがこんなに追い上げているんだぞ、とドヤっていました。
本文には「週末にこの辺
をいろいろ勉強していて、だいたい大雑把に状況がつかめました」と書いてあります。
週
末をまるまる使って、表が２枚、参照リンクが10本。
ソースは英語のまとめサイトと
Statistaです。
ちゃんと自分でリサーチできる、人気ライターですね。
ちなみに、その前の週には、こういう記事も書いていました。
『週刊金融日記 第六百三十号 エーアイブームは大山鳴動して鼠一匹！
これから生成エーアイの大がっかりイ
ヤーが始まります』
鼠一匹どころか、当時、簡単な中学生の数学の演習問題も間違えていたのに、その鼠は
２年で数学の未解決問題を解くようになり、僕の余暇の時間をぜんぶ食い尽くす化け物に
育ちました（笑）。
では、さいきんの号を見てみましょうか。
７月に書いたメモリ半導体のレポートです。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十号 メモリ半導体株（Micron、SK hynix、Samsung、Kioxia）の低
PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか 供給編』
ここでは、韓国勢のSK hynixとSamsungが韓国政府と結んだ総額896兆ウォンの投資計
画を解剖し、龍仁半導体クラスターの第１工場の６つのクリーンルームにいつ装置が搬入
され、月産36万枚に達するのが何年何月なのか、平沢のメガファブP5の稼働時期、さらに
はHBM4の歩留まりまで追跡しています。
アメリカのMicronがニューヨークやアイダホ、
そして広島工場に流し込むコンクリートの量やCHIPS法の補助金、日本のキオクシアが北
上K2で進める第10世代BiCS FLASHのビット密度の向上率、果ては中国のCXMT（長?メ
モリ）のSTARしじょうでの超巨額アイピーオーの目論見書や、YMTC（長江メモリ）の武漢第３工場
における製造装置の国産化比率まで、一次資料や各国の業界紙、専門調査会社のレポート
の二次報道、ウェハー投入能力と販売可能ビットのタイムラグを年表レベルで検証しまし
あるいは、９月のエーアイデータセンターの電力問題を扱った号はどうでしょうか。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十七号 エーアイデータセンター建設ラッシュのボトルネックの電力問題につい
て関連企業を網羅しながら一気に解説します』
データセンターの電力を手っ取り早く確保するために天然ガス火力にじゅようが殺到し、
GE Vernova、Siemens Energy、三菱重工の大型ガスタービンのバックログが2031年まで
埋まっている話から、CaterpillarやCumminsの常用エンジン、Bloom Energyの燃料電
池、さらには中国が世界の太陽光パネルの９割、セルの９割以上を握り、CATLの蓄電シ
ステム（BESS）が世界を席巻している構造、そして米国の安全保障規制（トランプ大
統領令やFCCのインバーター規制）を迂回して中東などの第三国で生まれる「米中合体メ
ガデータセンター」というシナリオまで、一気に網羅しました。
一般読者向けに書く経済記事ですが、２年前は国別の自動車生産台数と会社別の自動車
販売台数のテーブルがひとつずつあって、世界の自動車産業をドヤ顔で論じていたのに、
さいきんでは、たとえば、半導体メモリ産業を語るには、どこの会社が何をどの程度作ってい
るかとか、そんなものは幼稚園レベルの話であって、大人なら、どこの工場が何をどれぐ
らい作っていて、それが時系列でどうやって推移していくか、というレベルの情報を、世
界に数十ある工場レベルで把握した上で、コラムを書かないといけないんですよ。
電力のコラムを書くなら、どの企業のガスタービンの受注残が何ギガワットで、いつまで埋ま
っているかまで知っていないと、話になりません。
ただの一介のライターが、２年前なら外資系証券会社のアナリストチームを何週間もカ
ンヅメにしてやっていたような調査を、１日や２日でこなすようになったわけです。
世間では「エーアイによって人間の仕事が奪われて暇になる」とか「知的生産性が上がって週
休３日や４日の優雅な生活がやってくる」などと、お花畑な未来予測を語っていた文化人
や評論家がたくさんいました。
しかし、現実はどうでしょうか。
エーアイという超絶に有能な部下たちが手に入った結果、起きたのは「暇になること」ではな
く「無限のタスクの増殖」でした。
いぜんなら「まあ、このテーマを掘り下げるには各国の現地ニュースや業界レポートを読
み込まないといけないし、週末の限られた時間じゃ無理だな」と諦めて適当なところで切
り上げていた壁が、エーアイによって消滅してしまったのです。
韓国語の専門紙だろうが、中国
の証券取引所の開示書類だろうが、米国の複雑な規制文書だろうが、エーアイを使えばリサーチ
できてしまいます。
リサーチできるなら、それをやらない手はないわけです。
しかし、エーアイがどれだけ優秀なレポートを上げてきても、それを読み込み、ファクトを精
査し、ハルシネーション（もっともらしい嘘）がないか必死にチェックし（チェックそ
のものを他のエーアイが支援したりもしますが）、いくつもの複雑な事象を一本の論理的なスト
ーリーに編み上げるのは、結局のところまだまだ人間の仕事です。
優秀な部下が100人で
きて、毎日猛烈なスピードで質の高い調査資料を僕のデスクに積み上げてくるようなもの
ですわ。
それを全部チェックして指示を出し、最終的な意思決定（原稿の執筆）をする
上司である僕が、忙しくならないわけがありません。
僕のMacBook Proはフル稼働し、熱を逃がすためのファンが唸りを上げ、僕の脳みそも
四六時中フル回転で、香港や東京、移動中の飛行機の中でも、常にエーアイから返ってきた資料
を読み込み、エーアイと議論し、唸りながら原稿を書いています。
生活の余裕なんて、文字通り
消えてなくなりました。
たとえば、トイレに行く、シャワーを浴びる前に、エーアイにタスクを
投げていなかったら、それは大きな機会損失になりますから、トイレに行きたかったら、
ここでどんな指示を出せば、こいつはいい仕事をするか？
トイレが終わったあとに出てく
る調査資料を想像しながら、指示を出しておかないといけません。
じゃあ、「そんなに大変なら、２年前のレベルに戻せばいいじゃないか」と思う人もい
るでしょう。
自動車の販売ランキングと生産ランキングの表をちょろっと貼って、「中国すごいです
ね、BYD来てますね」と書いていれば、週末の数時間で仕事は終わります。
しかし、そんなことは絶対にできないのです。
なぜなら、ライバルのライターたちも、
メディアも、そして読者自身も、同じように最新のエーアイで完全武装しているからです。
いまや、世の中の書き手もアナリストも、エーアイを使って、かつてないスピードと密度で情
報を発信しています。
当然、読者の側も目が肥えまくっています。
このエーアイ時代の深度とス
ピードについていけない評論家とかは、早々に脱落していくと思いますわ。
もし僕が今、２年前のような国別自動車生産台数と会社別自動車販売台数ぐらいのデー
タを元に自動車産業について語っちゃうコラムを配信したらどうなるでしょうか。
読者か
らは、一瞬で「なんだこの記事、薄すぎるだろ」「こんなの無料エーアイに聞けば３秒で出てく
るわ」と見切りをつけられるだけですね。
自分がこの情報発信というレースで生き残り、読者に納得してもらうためには、ライバ
ルたちがエーアイを使って提供してくる高いクオリティをさらに上回る、圧倒的な情報量と独自
の洞察を提供し続けなければなりません。
これ、まさにルイス・キャロルの『鏡の国のアリス』に出てくる「赤の女王のレース」
そのものです。
「その場にとどまるためには、全力で走り続けなければならない。
もし別の場所に行きた
いのなら、少なくともその２倍の速さで走らなければならない」
エーアイというテクノロジーの進化によって、人間は楽になるどころか、エーアイの走る猛烈なスピ
ードに合わせて、自分自身も心臓が張り裂けそうな勢いで全力疾走し続けなければ、一瞬
で振り落とされる世界になってしまったわけです。
経済学的に見れば、これは極めて当たり前すぎる現象です。
エーアイによって知的生産性は劇的に「爆上げ」しました。
しかし、参加者全員の生産性が10
倍になれば、10倍のアウトプットを出すことは特別なことでも何でもなく、単なる「業界
の最低限の参加資格（足切りライン）」になるだけです。
生産性向上の果実は、過酷な市
場競争の中で一瞬にしてすべて「クオリティのインフレ」に飲み込まれてしまいました。
その結果、知的労働者は信じられないほど忙しくなり、生活のよゆうを失い、心身をすり
減らしています。
そして、資本主義の最も冷酷な真実は、だからといってメルマガの購読
料を10倍に値上げできるわけではない、ということです。
当たり前ですね。
メモリが値上
がりしているといっても、僕が大学生のころ、128MBのディーラムが２万円ぐらいしまし
た。
いまは16GBぐらいなんで、同じ値段で100倍以上ですよ。
ビット当たりにしたら、
足元で値上がりしていても、僕が大学生のころよりは圧倒的に安い。
僕たち、知的労働者
のアウトプットもこれと同じで、ムーアの法則みたいに我々もエーアイとともに進化していかな
いといけないわけです。
売上も収入もほとんど変わらないまま、求められる労働の密度とアウトプットの要求水
準だけが垂直立ち上げで跳ね上がり、知的生産性は爆上がりしたのに、豊かさや余暇には
まったく結びつきません。
一見、これは見事なまでのディストピアです。
しかし、僕にとって、知的生産こそが喜びであり、目的です。
お金なんか、正直、増え
ても減っても何も変わりません。
お金は二の次なので、この状況は、とても良いですね。
こんごは、知的労働は、これまで10人でやっていたものが、エーアイで武装したとりわけ優秀な
１人や２人でやるようになるかもしれません。
また、学生を見ていても、ほとんどの学
生は、勉学は単位をもらい卒業するために仕方なくやっているようなところがあるので、
エーアイで楽をして、むしろバカになっています。
しかし、一握りの学生は、このエーアイを使って、
学びの質と量を加速しています。
もう、知的労働は、こういうエーアイによってできた強化人間
みたいな人たちしか生き残らないかもしれません。
中学受験をする子供は、やはり12歳とかなんでちんたらしていますが、入試まであと１
ヶ月となると真剣に勉強をはじめます。
親も真剣です。
僕は、すべての人たちに、入試10
日前の受験生のように毎日生きてほしいと願っています。
やはり、真剣にがんばっている
人たちは違いますからね。
エーアイが広まり、かつてのなんばいもがんばらないと、現在の位置にとどまっていることすらで
きなくなりました。
このエーアイ大競争時代を歓迎し、僕たちも最後まで全力で走り抜けましょう！
２．こんしゅうのマーケット
2026年9月4日-2026年9月11日の週間パフォーマンス
[EN]TOPIX:       4028.30, -1.8% (1w), +17.6% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Nikkei225:  64011.34, -1.6% (1w), +27.2% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]S&P500:      7656.98, -0.8% (1w), +11.9% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]USD/JPY:      153.55, -1.7% (1w),  -1.8% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]EUR/JPY:      178.14, -1.8% (1w),  -3.0% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Oil(WTI Fut): 100.05, +9.4% (1w), +74.2% (YTD)[/EN]
トランプ「共和党勝利なら5000ドル給付」、オープンエーアイが数学の難問突破、エーアイ開発減
速論でも軍拡競争は止まらない（金融日記 Weekly 2026/9/4-2026/9/11）
せんしゅう（9月4日−11日）のかぶしきしじょうは、原油高と金利上昇を嫌気して全体として軟調だっ
た。
TOPIXは週間で1.8％、日経平均は1.6％、S&P500は0.8％下落した。
ホルムズ海峡
を巡る緊張に加え、サウジアラビアの原油輸送網にも不安が広がり、WTI原油先物は9.4％
上昇して100ドル台に乗せた。
インフレ再燃への警戒から米10年金利は一時５％目前まで
上昇したいっぽう、日銀の追加利上げ観測からドル円は一時152円台まで円高となった。
個別
株では、エーアイ関連でも明暗が分かれ、AMD（+8.1％）、メタ（+5.1％）が上昇するいっぽう、
エヌビディア（-5.1％）、Micron（-4.1％）は下落した。
日本ではキオクシアがほぼ横ばい（
-0.1％）だったのに対し、オープンエーアイへの巨額出資で知られるソフトバンクGは17.0％高と突
出した。
そのソフトバンクGを一気に買い上げる材料となったのが、オープンエーアイによる数学の大難
問への挑戦である。
オープンエーアイは、ジーピーティー-6 Astraより「大幅に能力が高い」という未公開の次
世代モデルを使い、約90年間未解決だった、３次元Navier?Stokes方程式の滑らかな解が
常に存在するのか、それとも特異点が生じ得るのかという難問に対し、有限時間で特異点
が生じることを示す解を提示した。
約１万のエーアイエージェントを同時稼働させ、約88時間で
解に到達し、その後ジーピーティー-6 Astraがさらに17時間かけてLeanによる形式化と検証を行っ
た。
まだ数学界で最終的に検証され、Clay数学研究所から正式認定されたわけではなく、
同時期に研究していた数学者との優先権を巡る論争もある。
それでも、オープンエーアイ自身が「
ジーピーティー-6 Astraより大幅に能力が高い」とする内部モデルがすでに動いているという事実は
衝撃的である。
ソフトバンクG株は９月に入って大きく上昇し、空売り勢には巨額の含み
損が発生した。
これは「エーアイはそろそろ性能向上の限界ではないか」という議論に対する、かなり強烈な
反証でもある。
チャットの文章が少しうまくなるというレベルではなく、人類が何十年も
解けなかった数学の問題にエーアイエージェント群が踏み込む段階へ来た。
科学、材料開発、創
薬、ソフトウェア、サイバーセキュリティなど、エーアイが経済価値を生む用途はむしろこれか
ら広がる。
これだけ能力が上がれば必要になる推論量も増え、ジーピーユー、HBM、ディーラム、
ナンドフラッシュ、ネットワーク、電力への需要も当然のように増えていく。
いっぽう、週末にはアンソロピックのDario Amodei シーイーオーが、エーアイの能力向上があまりに速すぎると
して、業界全体で開発速度を意図的に落とすことを呼びかけた。
Sam Altmanもオープンエーアイが
かいはつを減速する可能性に言及し、Elon Muskも安全性を理由とする減速論に賛意を示して
いる。
こうした発言を受けて、エーアイデータセンター投資や半導体需要まで減速するのではな
いか、という懸念がしじょうに出るのは理解できる。
しかし筆者は、この「みんなで少しゆっくりやりましょう」という話が長期的に機能す
るとはまったく考えていない。
なぜなら、これは企業間競争であると同時に国家間の軍拡
競争だからだ。
仮にオープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、グーグル、xAIが揃って開発速度を落として
も、中国のDeepSeekやKimiをはじめとする研究陣が同じように止まる保証はどこにもな
い。
米国が安全のために半年休めば、その半年は中国が差を詰める時間になる。
中国が止
まらないなら米国政府は米国企業に再びアクセルを踏ませる。
逆もまた同じである。
しか
も各社の間でも、一社だけ本気でかいはつを止めれば顧客、人材、資本を競合に奪われる。
こ
のゲームには自主的な減速が安定した均衡になる仕組みがない。
エーアイと半導体を巡る天井な
き軍拡競争は、誰かが危険だと言った程度では決して終わらない。
むしろ危険なほど強力
だと分かったからこそ、国家安全保障上、誰も降りられなくなるのである。
エーアイ開発競争
は、その危険性ゆえにむしろ加速していくのだ。
マクロでは、トランプ大統領が11月の中間選挙で共和党が上下両院を維持すれば、成人
１人当たり5000ドルの「トランプ配当」を支給すると表明したこともしじょうを騒がせた。
対
象次第では１兆ドルを超える巨額財政政策となり、実現には議会承認も必要で、共和党内
からも財政赤字とインフレを悪化させるとの批判が出ている。
原油が100ドルを超え、長
期金利も５％に迫るなかで１兆ドルきぼの現金を配るなら、かぶしきしじょうへの刺激策になる一
方、債券しじょうには多少のストレスがかかるかもしれない。
こんしゅうは15−16日のFOMCと17−18日の日銀会合が最大の焦点になる。
米国では原油高
と8月CPIを受けて利上げ観測が強まっており、FOMCではウォーシュ議長がインフレに
どこまで強硬な姿勢を示すかが重要だ。
日本では全国CPIに加え、日銀の追加利上げと今
後の利上げペースが焦点となる。
さらに中東では、攻撃を受けたサウジの東西パイプライ
ンが長期停止すれば、世界きょうきゅうの約4％に相当する輸送能力が失われ、供給逼迫が一段と
深刻化する可能性がある。
短期的にはエーアイ開発減速論よりも、100ドルを超えた原油と日米
の金融政策の方が株価を大きく動かすことになりそうだ。
【解説】 トランプ氏、米中間選挙で勝利なら全成人に5000ドル支給と表明　本当に可
能なのか
米長期金利に「トランプ・ショック」、５パーセントに迫る　バイバック効かず
円、一時152円台後半に上昇　７カ月ぶり水準、利上げ加速観測
迫る「第２のホルムズ海峡危機」　サウジの原油パイプライン稼働停止
オープンエーアイ、ミレニアム懸賞問題「ナビエ・ストークス方程式」の難問を解決したと発表
オープンエーアイ、数学の大難問をエーアイが解いたと発表。
数学者が研究経緯に異議
ソフトバンクGの空売り勢、ふくみそん急拡大　オープンエーアイ新モデル期待で株高
アンソロピックシーイーオー、競合他社に「エーアイかいはつの減速」呼びかけ
週刊金融日記 第七百四十五号 なぜエーアイと半導体をめぐる天井なき果てしなき軍拡競争は決して避
けられない運命なのか、他
Xサブスク（3USD/月）で、主要企業の決算分析や、エーアイバブルの現在位置について筆者
とエーアイの対談記事が読めます。
購読希望の方は、アップルにピンハネされるiPhoneアプリか
らではなく、スマホやPCのブラウザからXのサイトを開き、そこで直接サブスクリプショ
ンを登録して、ついでに、イーロン・マスク氏の宇宙開発も同時に応援してください。
9月14日(月)
9月15日(火)
日7月第3次産業活動指数
日20年国債入札
米FOMC（-9/16）
米9月ニューヨーク連銀製造業景気指数
米20年国債入札
中国8月小売売上高
中国8月固定資産投資
中国8月鉱工業生産指数
独9月ZEW景況感指数
9月16日(水)
日7月機械受注
日8月貿易統計
米8月輸出・輸入物価指数
米8月小売売上高
米9月NAHB住宅市場指数
米7月企業在庫
米ウォーシュエフアールビー議長会見
米7月対米証券投資
9月17日(木)
日銀金融政策決定会合（-9/18）
日8月首都圏マンション販売
東京ゲームショウ2026（-9/21）
米8月建設許可・住宅着工件数
米9月フィラデルフィア連銀製造業景気指数
米8月NAR仮契約住宅販売指数
9月18日(金)
日8月全国しょうひ者物価指数
植田日銀総裁会見
米8月鉱工業生産
米8月設備稼働率
米8月景気先行指数
9月19日(土)
9月20日(日)
３．ブログではいえないお店
-品川駅周辺のラーメンの話
ビッグテックの決算や、エーアイブームについての大変な考察など、重いタスクが続いてい
て、後回しになっていたんですが、とうとう、品川駅周辺のレストラン特集のXサブス
ク記事を配信できました。
金融日記 レストランリスト No.6 飲食不毛の地と言われる品川駅周辺の美味しいお店
それで、こんしゅうは、Xサブスク記事の方でも書いた品川のラーメンの話です。
品川は飲食
不毛の地と言われていますが、その中でも特にラーメンが不毛なんですよ！
昔は高輪口側の京急品川駅の高架下に「品達（しなたつ）」というラーメンのフードテ
ーマパークがあって、蒙古タンメン中本とか、なんつッ亭とか、せたが屋とか、東京の
有名店が７軒も集まっていて、品川駅でも一流のラーメンが食べられたんです。
しかし、
品川駅の改良工事の影響で、2020年３月にこれが閉館してしまいました。
それで、あんなにサラリーマンがたくさんいるのに、品川駅はラーメン不毛地帯になっ
たわけです。
いくつかそれなりのラーメン屋はあるんですが、わざわざ行くほどでもない
微妙なところばかりなんですよね。
しかし、最近、品川駅のお隣の三田とか五反田とかのラーメン激戦区でもやっていける
レベルのラーメン屋がひとつできていました！
まあ、チェーン店なんですけどね。
らぁ麺 はやし田 品川港南口店
東京都港区港南2-2-14 協和ビル 1F
03-6712-8558
この品川港南口店は2025年にできたばかりで、店内はまだ新しく、木目調で清潔感があ
って、いい感じです。
看板は醤油らぁ麺で、鶏の出汁と鶏油のコクが効いた澄んだスープに、歯切れのいい細
麺ストレート、長い穂先メンマ、味玉、と、いまどきの洗練された淡麗ラーメンですね。
スープが澄んでて、鶏の出汁も効いているみたいで、美味かったです。
品川以外でもや
っていける一流のラーメンですね。
港南口から徒歩２分で、朝10時から夜23時まで通しで営業しているので、昼時をハズし
て行くといいでしょう。
夜は行列ができていることもありますが、回転が早いのですぐに
入れます。
もうひとつは、昔からあって、居酒屋兼ラーメン屋みたいな感じで、正直、わざわざ紹
介するほどのお店でもないんですけど、実際に、世界的な美食家の僕も、品川駅に来た時
は、なんどかリピートしているんで、書いておきます。
博多らーめん由丸 品川港南店
東京都港区港南2-2-6 長山ビル 2F
03-5783-4070
博多ラーメンなんで、そりゃあ、まあまあ以上に美味いです。
ラーメン不毛地帯となっ
た品川では、貴重な存在ですね。
場所は港南口から歩いて５分ぐらい、雑居ビルの２階で
豚骨をじっくり炊いた濃厚豚骨スープに、極細ストレート麺、キクラゲとネギとチャー
シュー、という由丸らーめんが930円で、替え玉もできます。
麺の硬さはもちろん選べま
まあ、ことさら騒ぐほどのもんでもない博多ラーメンなんですが、品川駅にあることに
意味がありますね。
それで、前述のように、ここは「ラーメン居酒屋」ですね。
焼餃子、牛すじ煮込み、ご
まさば、明太子をトッピングできるポテサラなんかの九州名物のつまみが安くて、生ビー
ルやハイボールを飲んで、シメに博多らーめん、という一連の流れが一軒で完結します。
出張帰りに品川でちょっと一杯ひっかけて、新幹線に乗る前にラーメンでシメる、という
用途には最適です。
そんなに人気店でもないんで、予約せずに入れて、まあ、3000円、4000円ぐらいでビ
ール飲んで満腹になれる安めの大衆店としては、こういうのでいいんですよね。
せんしゅう号でも書きましたが、このように、大規模再かいはつは10年後にはすごいことになるっ
て分かりきっていても、株と違って、不動産は10年はずっと工事中で、新しいお店も進出
してこないし、10年工事中の街に住むディスカウントがかかるから、不動産の爆上げは再
かいはつが完了してから始まったりするんですよね。
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.1
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.2
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.3
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.4
後世に残す金融日記レストランリスト No.5
金融日記 レストランリスト No.6 飲食不毛の地と言われる品川駅周辺の美味しいお店
しんせん・南油服装卸売しじょうの歩き方 2026年
４．ふじさわかずきの身もフタもない人生相談
-日本の長期金利４％時代に海外駐在家庭はどう生活防衛すべきでしょうか
日本も長期金利４％が現実味を帯びるような「金利のある世界」になってきましたが、こ
うした環境で、一般家庭はどのように生活防衛すべきだと考えますか？
私は現在海外駐在中で、外貨建て資産は円安もあって円換算では膨らんでいます。
いっぽう、いずれ日本に帰国する予定で、６歳の子どもがおり、妻も現在は駐妻で専業主婦で
帰国後は住宅、教育費、生活費など円での支出が一気に増えるので、今のうちに円資産を
増やすべきなのか、むしろ外貨資産を維持すべきなのか、住宅を買うべきなのか賃貸を続
けるべきなのか、少し悩んでいます。
藤沢先生なら、こういう40代の海外駐在家庭が日本帰国に向けて、資産配分や住居をどう
設計しますか？
-ふじさわかずきの回答
日本の投資家は日本円持って日本株ばかり買う、香港の投資家は香港ドル持って香港株式
しじょうに上場されている株ばかり買う……と、こういうのをファイナンスで「ホームカント
リーバイアス」と言います。
それで、今どき、ドルを円に替えたりとか、そういうのの手数料なんか微々たるもので、
日本に住んでるから日本円で投資して……みたいなのは非合理的な行動というのが僕の考
えです。
もちろん、基本的にどこの国も税金とかは自国の金融商品のほうがだいたい税制がシンプ
ルで税率も低いことが多く、タックス最適化の話はありますが。
実際、僕もそれでイーティーエフとか同じような中身なら、香港上場のものを好むんで、先日も、ア
メリカのイーティーエフでもなく韓国の現物株でもなく、香港に上場されているKOSPIのイーティーエフを買
った話をしましたね。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十六号 SKハイニックス株を買いたいのですがADR（米国預託証券）で
買うと為替や取引手数料がかかる上に30％もプレミアムがついている件と所長がKOSPIを
買った理由について』
それで、海外駐在で、お子さんがいて、バリバリ仕事をしている40代なら、わざわざ日本
の金利とか日本円での投資みたいなスペシフィックなちまちましたことをいろいろ考える
だけ時間と労力の無駄なんで、投資ならふつうに世界株インデックスとか、あと、不動産
なら自分が住むためのものだけ考えてればいいと思いますよ。
なんというか、僕的には、エーアイ革命という人類がこれからどうなるかって時に、金利が
0.5パーセント上がるとか上がらないとか、そういうちまちました話は、正直、どうでもいいんで
すよね。
『なぜ投資のプロはサルに負けるのか？
』
-しんせんへの直行便と買い物旅行について
いつもメルマガ楽しみにしております。
ところで、ANAの羽田からしんせんへの直行便が復活したように見えます。
この機に、11月頃にまたしんせんへ買い物旅行に行こうかと思っていますが、APECにより
浄化される雰囲気、気配など、なにかありましたら教えていただきたいです。
-ふじさわかずきの回答
まあ、復活したんですけど、たとえば、らいしゅうの９月のシルバーウィークだと、しんせんが往
復20万円とかしますね（笑）。
早苗が、ファンサービスで、シーさんに喧嘩売りに行ったりして、まあ、いらんことして
くれたなあ、とは思いますが、この値段だと香港国際空港から、空港を出ないで乗るフェ
リーでしんせんの蛇口クルーズセンターに行って入国手続きする方法のほうがだいぶいい
な、と思って、香港の値段を調べたら、香港でも連休なんで往復14万円とかするんです
まあ、11月のチケットは、連休でもだいぶ安くなっていますが。
さて、APECにより浄化される雰囲気、気配などは全くありませんが、なんせ、中国政府
はそういうことって、あしたからやる、と急に発表して、本当にあしたからやるところですか
らね（笑）。
このメルマガで繰り返し言っていますが、東南アジアのリゾートも、銀座の鮨も、沖縄や
北海道旅行も、いい時期って長くは続かないんですよ。
すごく安く、こんなサービスを受けられるんか！
というものがあったら、早いところ行っ
ておかないと、どんどん値段上がって、サービス悪くなるんですよね。
そういう意味で、僕は中国メインランドの旅行をたびたび勧めているわけですわ。
東京⇔しんせん　シルバーウィーク直行便
東京⇔香港　シルバーウィーク直行便
東京⇔しんせん　11月勤労感謝の日の連休
『週刊金融日記 第七百二十三号 東京⇔しんせん直行便が激減してしんせんに行くにも香港経由になっ
たこととしんせん・香港の街角景気』
『週刊金融日記 第七百二十五号 ジーディーピー350兆円もある粤港澳大湾区（Greater Bay Area）は観光地
としてもとてつもないです、【保存版】南油服装卸売市場と華強北などディープしんせん』
しんせん・南油服装卸売しじょうの歩き方 2026年（Xサブスク）
-ブセナテラス以外の沖縄のおすすめホテルをご教示ください
藤沢所長、いつも楽しくメルマガやXを拝読しております。
だいぶ前の話になりますが、メルマガで所長がおすすめされていた「ザ・ブセナテラス」
に宿泊したのですが、ホスピタリティ・施設ともに期待以上で、大変素晴らしい滞在にな
りました。
良質な情報を共有していただき、本当にありがとうございました。
近々、再び沖縄旅行を計画をしており、ホテル選びで悩んでおります。
そこで質問なのですが、ブセナテラス以外で所長が実際に宿泊されたり、特におすすめし
たいと感じられた沖縄本島（または離島）のホテルはございますでしょうか。
もし過去のメルマガのバックナンバー等ですでに詳しく言及されている回などがございま
したら、号数なども合わせてご教示いただけますと幸いです。
また沖縄滞在中の観光スポット（及び飲食店）などもオススメがありましたらお伺いし
たいです。
これからもメルマガを楽しみにしております。
ご多忙中とは存じますが、ご回答いただけましたら嬉しく思います。
-ふじさわかずきの回答
僕の中で沖縄ブームはもう10年以上も前の話なんですよね。
2012年のブログ記事がありますが、あの頃はLCCとか出てきて、JALとかANAとかの数分
の１ぐらいの値段で、沖縄とか北海道とか往復１万円ちょっととかで行けたんですよ。
その頃は、ネットでもLCCをみんなバカにして、差別するようなことが盛んで、貧乏人が
乗るもんとか、LCCなんかに乗ったら事故で死ぬ確率が高いとか、もうめちゃくちゃだっ
たんですわ。
それで、僕は、世界のLCCの事故率とか調べて、別にLCCが事故率が高いわけでも何でも
なく、空港でもチェックインのカウンターがいちばん端っことか、ターミナルも遠いが
ち、機内食とかそういうサービスはなくて（飛行機で一番良いサービスはサービスが何
もないことです）、ドリンクとかも有料、というぐらいで、それで数分の１ってめちゃく
ちゃ得じゃん、と思って、LCCでいろいろ旅行しておったわけです。
LCCでサクッと沖縄　金融日記 2012年7月27日
その頃は、沖縄とか北海道とかもいまみたいに混んでなくて、ブセナテラス最高じゃん、
みたいに思っておりました。
『週刊金融日記 第十六号 沖縄の素敵なリゾートホテル』
『週刊金融日記 第七十六号 おとなの沖縄旅行初心者コース』
『週刊金融日記 第百五十四号 やっぱり避粉地は沖縄』
他にも沖縄のいろいろなリゾートホテルに行ったんですわ。
その後にできた、ハレクラニとかも含めてね。
結論から言うと、ブセナテラスがさいしょにして最高でした。
それで、２、３年前にブセナテラスに行こうとしたら、もうなんか一泊15万円とかして、
ああ、もうアカンな、と。
僕がさいごに沖縄に行ったのは、もう５年ぐらい前のような気がしますから、状況が変わっ
ているかもしれませんが、まあ、ブセナテラスを超えるところはなくて、他は、Airbnbで
浜辺の大きい家を借りるとかそんな感じですね。
あと、沖縄旅行って、こういうリゾートホテルにずっと滞在するんじゃなくて、美ら海水
族館とかいろいろ行きたいなら、レンタカーが必須ですね。
僕はよく言ってるんですが、LCCに偏見があって、ネットとかで批判が盛り上がってると
きにLCC使って、LCCで行きやすい観光地に行かないといけないし、銀座の鮨も2010年代
のデフレ時代に１人２万円の時に行かないといけないんですよね。
銀座の鮨なんか、いま同じもんというか、むしろ日本はシーフードが乱獲で減っているか
ら、昔より悪い上に、客がどんだけでも来るし、来る客も味が分からない金持ち外国人と
かになってるからサービスも悪いんですよ。
そうなってから、１人８万円で行っても仕方ないんですよね。
その点から言うと、僕は沖縄よりは、ベトナムのダナンとか、中国の青島とか行ってみた
いなあ、と。
ダナンは何回か行ったことあって、ネット情報見てると、まだ良さそうですね。
中国の青島とか、まだ、行ってないんで行きたいですわ。
『週刊金融日記 第三百三十三号 ベトナム旅行 その３ ダナン・ホイアン編』
-小型原発銘柄に将来性はありますか
お世話になっております。
原子力にもお詳しい藤沢所長のご見解を伺いたく存じます。
現在、米国株のSMR（ニュースケールパワー）、オクロに投資をしております。
[EN]●NuScale Power Corporation (SMR)[/EN]
[EN]●Oklo Inc. (OKLO)[/EN]
エーアイによる電力逼迫を解決する手段として小型原発に注目しています。
トランプ大統領就任から一時株価は急騰したものの現在は低迷している状況です。
藤沢所長から見て小型原発の将来性についてどのようにお考えでしょうか？
上記で挙げた２銘柄とも大きなふくみそんで損切りするか、将来性に賭けて保有継続するか悩
んでおります。
ご助言を頂けますと幸いでございます。
-ふじさわかずきの回答
まず大前提として、僕は原子力ファンで、原発推進の本まで書いています。
原子力は理想的な発電方法だという基本的な考えは、いまも全く変わっていません。
『反原発の不都合な真実』
すでに大型の軽水炉は技術が確立され、安全に運転してきた実績もあります。
適切な安全対策と管理を前提に、これをたくさん造ればいいわけです。
エーアイ用の電気だから、新しいタイプの原子炉で発電しなければいけない理由はありません。
しかし、現実には政治の壁があります。
原子爆弾を連想してしまい、原発を同じように危険なものと考える人が多数ですね。
これは科学的には間違いですが、民主主義では、その不安も票になります。
政治家は有権者の感情に阿るので、政治的コストがどんどん上がってしまいます。
技術的には低コストを目指せる電源でも、政治的コストを入れると安くなくなるんですよ
それで、問題なのは、小型原発や新型原発にしても、この問題は消えないということで
１基当たりの合意形成の負担が出力に比例して小さくなるわけではないので、同じ電力を
多くの立地点で確保しようとすれば、発電量当たりの政治的コストは、むしろ上がりま
データセンターの建設ですら反対運動が起きる米国で、「小型原発も併設します。
小型だ
から安全です！
」と言ったところで、すんなり進むようには思えません。
そこで活路になるのが、第七百四十七号で書いた、米国のエーアイ企業が第三国にデータセンターを造
るシナリオです。
その電源として、米国などの工場で製造した小型炉も一緒に輸出できます。
電力と投資を必要とし、政府が立地を積極的に進められる国で、データセンターと電源を
まとめて整備するわけです。
小型炉は、工場で標準化して造った機器を運び、需要に合わせて増設する形を狙えます。
僕は、この輸出のしやすさが小型炉の最大のメリットになり得ると思っています。
もちろん、現地の許認可や工事、運転体制は必要ですが、しじょうを米国内だけに限定して考
える必要はありません。
ということで、小型炉に活路があるとすれば、第七百四十七号で解説した、アメリカのデータ
センターを第三国にバンバン作る話がどれだけ進展するかじゃないんですかね。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十七号 エーアイデータセンター建設ラッシュのボトルネックの電力問題につい
て関連企業を網羅しながら一気に解説します』
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。